all right so we're gonna switch gears
again today and we're gonna move off of
kind of pure genetics and start to talk
about molecular genetics and I want to
start with the concept of let's say you
want to identify a piece of DNA purify
it and propagate it so that you have it
for future use use and so the process of
doing this is known as cloning and it's
the process of if you will purifying and
propagating a piece of DNA in an in an
organism
okay so sort of the goal for this
lecture is for you to know how if you
wanted to let's say identify a piece of
DNA maybe you're interested in a piece
of DNA that contains a given gene how
would you go go about getting that DNA
in a state that can be propagated sort
of on and on and how can you identify
the piece of DNA you want okay and so
one tool that we're going to use is
we're going to use an organism bacteria
as a tool um so I'll draw my sample
bacterial cell here could be something
like e.coli just some bacterium and
you'll recall when we talked about when
I talked about cells a few weeks ago
bacteria and prokaryotic cells have a
chromosome called the nucleoid that's
present inside all right so that's the
bacterial chromosome but bacteria can
also have extra chromosomal pieces of
DNA that are called plasmids that exist
in their cytoplasm
these are plasmids
and these extra chromosomal pieces of
DNA replicate independently of the
chromosome and they can persist in the
bacterial cell and be passed on to the
daughters of this bacterial cell as the
bacterial cells divide okay so if we
focus on an individual plasmid what a
plasmid would look like often they have
a cassette or a gene that confers
antibiotic resistance and that's often
the reason that these bacteria are
harboring these plasmids because it
gives them a sort of advantage if
they're exposed to a certain antibiotic
from a predator organism so this would
confer antibiotic resistance one common
example is ampicillin resistance which
I'll abbreviate just amp with the are
next to it okay but these plasmids for
them to propagate from bacterial cell to
bacterial cell they also need to be able
to undergo replication so they also have
what is known as an origin of
replication which is often abbreviated
ori which basically allows this plasmid
to be replicated such that copies of the
plasmid are passed on to the subsequent
generation of bacteria okay and we can
take advantage of this plasmid system in
bacteria because we could take let's say
a piece of foreign DNA and this foreign
DNA could be of eukaryotic origin we
could take a piece of eukaryotic DNA and
insert it inside of this plasmid and we
can basically use the plasmid as a sort
of platform or a vac
Derr to carry the piece of DNA that we
might be interested in and to use the
bacteria to replicate that DNA and pass
it on to its descendants so that you
essentially have a clone of bacteria and
you have a clone of this DNA in a given
bacterial population so again this would
have an origin and maybe an ampicillin
resistance to it so how would you
determine whether or not bacteria have a
plasmid in it you think of an experiment
you could do to determine whether the
bacteria has this plasmid Stephon
exactly so what Stephen suggested is
that if if he wanted to know whether or
not this bacteria had the plasmid in it
he would add ampicillin to the media and
if the bacteria doesn't have the plasmid
it won't be able to grow but if it has
the plasmid it encodes this gene that
confers ampicillin resistance and it
will thus be able to grow okay so that's
exactly right so you're able to select
for bacteria with a given plasmid by
simply growing it on media that contains
an antibiotic okay I now want to go
through steps in cloning a piece of DNA
and we'll go through it sort of as a
series of ordered steps so you can see
how the process works I'm gonna start
with a step to cut the DNA after cutting
the DNA we'll then mix pieces together
once we mix the pieces together we'll do
something known as a ligation and I'll
explain that to you in just a minute and
then finally we'll end with selecting
the plasmids that have the piece of
foreign DNA that we want and this is
known as recombinant DNA because you've
recombined a piece of DNA from one
organism it could be a eukaryotic
organism like humans with a piece of DNA
that's from a prokaryotic cell a
bacterium okay so we then have some sort
of selection process
okay so we're gonna go through this step
by step and we're gonna start with
cutting DNA okay so cutting DNA and it
turns out we've talked about what type
of enzyme do you think would cut DNA not
just generally not as specific as what's
up on the slide what type of enzyme
would cleave DNA think about what how
enzymes are named yes so Stephen
suggested the DNA's which is a really
good suggestion right so enzyme that
will cut DNA would be a DNA's another
word for that as a nuclease it's some
type of nucleus and the type of nucleus
we're going to talk about is going to be
an endonuclease we talked about
exonucleases which chew DNA from the
ends in the context of DNA replication
what would in endonucleases is it's a
nucleus that's going to recognize a
fragment of DNA and cleave it in the
middle so it doesn't require an end it's
going to chop it right in the middle
okay and there's a type of endonuclease
and these are called restriction
endonucleases
they are nucleases that are natively
present in a lot of different bacteria
and these restriction endonucleases
essentially look through the DNA
sequence and they recognize a specific
sequence of nucleotides and make a cut
right at that sequence okay so I have a
few examples to show you here the first
is this eco r1 restriction endonuclease
eco r1 so rich from eco lie and it
recognizes the sequence GA
ATTC so it recognizes the six nucleotide
sequence and it Cleaves the
double-stranded DNA on the top strand
between the G and the a and on the
bottom strand between the G and the a
okay
and you can see that the two cuts are
staggered so when this cut is made it
leaves the DNA with two ends and they're
sticky because there's a five-prime
overhang at each end so each end has
this TTA a sequence and these nucleotide
bases can base pair with the complement
complementary sequence so this sequence
could base pair with the sequence that
has an end a ATT okay so these two ends
that I've generated here could stick to
each other or there could be other ends
that have the TTA a sequence that could
stick to them okay so another example is
this kpn one endonuclease and this is
from a different bacterium but again it
Cleaves the DNA on the two strands and
this time it Cleaves the top strand
farther down the sequence and that
generates what's known as a three prime
overhang but again you have an overhang
so this is what is known as having a
sticky end
because again these nucleotides are
available to base pair with their
complementary sequence the final type of
restriction enzyme that I'll tell you
about is eco r5 which is a different
enzyme from eco lie and this generates a
break but this time it cuts at the same
position on both DNA strands and that
generates an end that's known as a blunt
end because there's no overhang and
there are no nucleotides that would sort
of basically recognize a complementary
sort of end like the sticky ends do okay
so these are several of many many
different types of restriction
endonucleases that are present in a wide
range of bacteria
okay so then now that you have a tool
that allows you to cut DNA you could
then cut DNA from two different sources
and I've outlined that here the vector
is what the plasmid DNA is commonly
referred to so we commonly refer to this
prokaryotic part of the plasmid the
vector DNA and the part that we're
trying to insert that's the foreign DNA
the insert okay that's just kind of the
lingo in the field okay so here I have a
plasmid it looks like a plasmid it has
an origin of replication it has
ampicillin resistance and it has this
eco r1 site which just means that this
DNA sequence has a g-a-a-t-t-c okay so
it's something that will be recognized
by this restriction endonuclease and
then if you cut this enzyme with eco r1
you start with the linear piece right so
I at six am started engineering this
here and so let's say I have my plasmid
DNA and I cut it at the eco r1 site then
I cleave it if you cleave a circle now
you have a linear piece of DNA okay but
it has sticky ends right and these
sticky ends so pretend that this is a
foreign piece of DNA this is my
eukaryotic DNA let's pretend it carries
the gene elastin and this has ends too
and if they're eco r1 ends then they
will be able to stick to the sticky ends
of the plasmid and if you just get one
sticking now you have this piece of DNA
which is two different fragments in
tandem but it's going to be moving
around in space in the cytoplasm and at
some point it might be recognized and
stick to the other eco r1 end and then
you have now a circular piece of DNA
again
but now your circular piece of DNA has
this piece of foreign DNA that's present
inside the vector which is the sort of
poster tape here okay so I just wanted
to show you that so you can kind of you
have to when you're doing molecular
biology you have to imagine these sort
of ends sticking to each other and how
they're gonna sort of wrap around and
connect for the final product okay so
let's say you get DNA and your DNA could
be eukaryotic DNA from let's say humans
or flies or whatever your favorite
eukaryote is and in the genome of that
organism there will be many restriction
sites but if you chop it up you will get
various fragments that have sticky ends
for eco r1 on both sides and then if you
mix the vector and the insert together
you have some probability of getting
that insert to be incorporated into the
vector okay and then once this is
present and ligated together you can
then put this into bacteria and it will
be replicated okay so we focused on
cutting but if you mix these together
like I showed you at the tape you're
gonna have sticky ends that come
together and stick together and you'll
eventually get a situation where you
have your insert so you have your insert
here that might have your gene of
interest and your vector DNA here but
when these things that Nishal II stick
together you don't have a single
molecule that where everything is
covalently attached right you just have
these base pair interactions between the
two overhangs as they stick to each
other through base pair interactions so
if we think about what's going on right
here
you have initially if we're thinking
about eco r1
a sequence that is nope sorry this
should be a see you have the this is the
nucleotide sequence but when it's
sticking together the top strand will
have a free five prime phosphate on this
adenosine and there will be no covalent
bond between this adenosine in this
guanosine okay so that's what the top
strand would look like the bottom strand
would look like this where there are
covalent bonds along the DNA backbone
OOP sorry mutation there okay right and
this is incorporated maybe in a broader
sequence and this bottom strand will
have a free five prime phosphate here
and a free three prime hydroxyl here but
there's no covalent bond here
there's no covalent bond here right so
at this stage you don't have a single
piece of DNA you have two pieces of DNA
that are interacting with each other
through base pair interactions okay so
eventually you want it to be a single
piece piece of DNA and so you have to
perform a step that is known as sorry
have my phosphate got in the way but you
want to perform what's known as a
ligation where you take something that's
just sticking together through
nucleotide base pair interactions and
you add a type of enzyme which is called
DNA ligase to catalyze the formation of
covalent bonds here in here so DNA
ligase is an enzyme that if you have a
free five prime phosphate here in a free
3 prime hydroxyl it'll catalyze the
formation of a phosphodiester bond
between these two big bases and the DNA
okay so this DNA ligase forms a
phosphodiester bond
and you go from having a no bond there
to having a bond so then you eventually
will get this sequence now where you
have where you have covalent bonds
between each of the base pairs and what
you see here is you've recreated the eco
r1 site okay so when you get to eco r1
sticky ends sort of recognizing each
other and sticking to each other and
then you like them together you recreate
that nuclei site so that you can cleave
it again with the eco r1 enzyme okay so
now moving on I'll move on right here so
the last step is that once we have
pieces of DNA with this insert and let's
say we're trying to find a piece of DNA
in from a eukaryotic organism we might
start with an animal we have to extract
its chromosomal DNA digest it with the
restriction enzyme and then we digest
the vector with the same restriction
enzyme and then we're going to make
we're gonna randomly insert these pieces
of DNA into different vectors such that
each bacteria who gets one of these
plasmids will be replicating a different
piece of DNA that's of eukaryotic origin
okay and this is what is known as a DNA
library okay so this is making a DNA
library and a DNA library is essentially
a collection of different pieces of DNA
that are from some source okay but
different bacterial clones will be
replicating a different piece of that
DNA okay so you can see the challenge
now is to find the needle and the
haystack right you're trying to find
that one piece of DNA which is the one
you're interested in
okay and I'll tell talk about several
strategies that you can use to find the
piece of DNA that you're interested in
I'll focus on selection but first I just
want to differentiate between two
different types of ways you could search
for a piece of DNA you could do a screen
and this is similar to what we talked
about on Monday where you look through a
whole population of individuals and you
look for a given phenotype so in the
case of flies right we talked about
house Morgan's lab was looking for
differences in eye color and that was a
screen because they looked through a ton
of normal flies to find the one they
want
okay another strategy would be to do
what's called a selection where you kill
off everything that's not what you want
by making the organism grow in some sort
of selective condition condition and
then you only allow the organisms to
grow that are the ones that you want
okay so this is called a selection and
I'm going to illustrate several examples
of selections just so that you get an
idea of how this works okay so the first
example I'll give is antibiotic
resistance and as Steven so kindly
pointed out earlier in the lecture the
way we can select for bacteria that have
taken up this plasmid is to select the
bacteria that grow in the presence of
the antibiotic okay so let's say you had
a population of bacteria and let's say
they started out being sensitive to an
antibiotic you could transform them with
DNA from a strain that's resistant and
maybe that's resistant strain has a
plasmid that has a gene that confers
antibiotic resistance in which case if
it's taken up by the sensitive bacteria
if you then grow it on a plate
that has the antibiotic you might get a
colony or a clone of cells that has
taken up the piece of DNA that you're
interested in in this case the piece of
DNA that confers antibiotic resistance
okay everyone see how that works so
you're selecting only the cells to grow
here that have taken up this antibiotic
resistance gene okay
I'm going to use another example now
from yeast and it involves functional
complementation and I'm gonna start with
something that involves the biosynthesis
of an essential amino acid and then I'm
gonna go to a more interesting case
which is a case where that involves an
experiment that evolved the
identification of the master regulator
of cell division in humans okay but
we'll start with just amino acid
biosynthesis and there are mutants of
yeast known as auxotrophs and these are
mutants mutant yeast or mutant
microorganisms that fail to produce an
essential nutrient okay so an auxotrophs
is a mutant that fails to make a
nutrient that's essential so fails to
make a nutrient and the opposite of an
ox
is called a proto TRO a proto troph
proto trope is a essentially a normal
functioning microorganism that's able to
produce all of the essential nutrients
that it needs in order to grow and
survive okay so this produces all
nutrients and so let's say you had an ox
atrophic
provide leucine to it it would fail to
grow okay so we'll start with the
leucine auxotrophs
and let's say you want to identify the
gene that's defective in this leucine
auxotrophs you'd perform a similar
strategy to this one where you'd have
your auxotrophs
that you're transforming so your
auxotrophs down here and you would
transform that strain with DNA from what
organism if you're trying to identify
the functional gene what what organism
would you use to produce the DNA you're
going to transform into that organism
Xavier is exactly right you'd use the
proto-truk right so in this case you use
DNA from the proto trove because the
proto truth has a functional copy of
that gene you know it does because it's
able to grow without adding leucine and
then you could take the auxotrophs
mutants that's transformed with DNA from
the proto-truk and you played it on
media and what should be a property of
the media should leucine be present or
absent carmen it should be lab absent
exactly right so you'd look on plates
that lack leucine or - for leucine and
you'd select for colonies that now are
all of a sudden able to grow on leucine
okay so you've restored the function of
leucine biosynthesis in this clone and
you've made it into a proto troph again
okay this is what's known as functional
complementation because you're taking a
cell that is defective in some function
and you're complimenting it you're
complimenting or rescuing the phenotype
okay now even as a former yeast
geneticist I don't find amino acid
biosynthesis and functional
complementation in the context of
leucine all that exciting so I want to
present one last example that involves
an experiment that is going to involve
the yeast cell cycle mutants and I'm
going to tell you about the experiment
that led to the cloning of the master
regulator of cell division in humans
okay and it involves a yeast mutant and
yeast specifically a yeast cell cycle
mutant and these yeast cell cycle
mutants are what are known as
conditional mutants they are isolated as
conditional mutants
meaning that these mutants are able to
grow under certain conditions but not
others and specifically the condition
they used is temperature so there are
temperature sensitive mutants these
cells can grow at 25 degrees but not at
37 degrees okay so this is known as a
temperature sensitive mutant where you
can propagate the mutant at one
temperature but then you can see if you
raise the temperature and then it stops
growing okay
and so you can see the mutant phenotype
because normal wild-type functional
yeast can grow at both temperatures okay
so this is a special type of mutant and
I'm gonna tell you about an experiment
done by Paul nurse who's an excellent
yeast geneticist and what he did was he
used these yeast cell cycle mutants to
identify the human gene for what's now
known as cyclin dependent kinase or cdk
for short okay this is the master
regulator of cell division in organisms
raining ranging from yeast all the way
up to humans okay but he used yeast as a
model system to identify this gene okay
and the process was he took yeast cells
and Paul nurse worked on fission yeast
cells which are rod shaped cells and he
identified yeast mutants
yeast mutants and he had a mutant into
the cdk gene of yeast he didn't really
know it at the time but the yeast cdk
mutant what he knew is that this mutant
was critically involved in the cell
cycle in numerous types of yeast so he
knew this is an important gene and what
he wanted to do was to identify if
humans had an equivalent gene that could
function in the same way okay so if you
just have the cdk mutant and do nothing
to it it will
not grow at 37 degrees okay but what he
did was to take a DNA library similar to
what I showed you before when you just
chop up DNA from an organism in this
case he's using a human DNA library and
he used a particular type of library but
I'm gonna skip over that for now for now
and come back to it later so he used a
human DNA library that's just a
collection of pieces of DNA from a human
source okay
so he's taking human DNA putting it into
a yeast plasmid and transforming yeast
with that human DNA and he's looking for
a piece of DNA that's able to complement
the cdk mutant meaning that the yeast
cells would then be able to grow at the
non-permissive temperature of 37 degrees
okay
so you then looks for on a plate four
colonies of yeast that are growing at
the non-permissive temperature of 37
degrees so if you didn't do anything
with this mutant if you didn't transform
in the DNA nothing would grow but he
identified pieces of human DNA that
rescued the phenotype of this mutant
okay and so these are yeast that have
the human gene for cdk and they now grow
okay and this is a functional
complementation experiment because
you're rescuing the growth of this yeast
now not with a yeast gene but with a
human gene okay and this human cdk gene
is so conserved across eukaryotes that
it's able to still function in a yeast
cell which is pretty amazing okay so
this just outlines the experiment here
north at 25 degrees these yeast mutants
can grow and form colonies and at that
temperature you can transform the East
with different pieces of human DNA most
of the human DNA is not going to be what
you want you're looking for the needle
in the haystack
so most of these are not going to grow
at 37 degree but you're looking for this
guy here that gets the human CDK and
that restores greet of the growth to
this mutant strain
okay so wallah you get a colony of cells
that are growing and boom Paul nurse
wins a Nobel Prize and the rest of the
Eastfield as well or a number of people
who are working on cell cycle mutants
this is one of the experiments that led
to the 2001 Nobel Prize for a bunch of
yeast cell cycle geneticists alright so
I've told you about how to find the
needle in the haystack and this was more
common when we didn't know the genome
sequence of an organism but now I want
to tell you how knowing the genome
sequence of an organism would allow you
to replicate and amplify a piece of DNA
in vitro okay
so I'm going to tell you about a an
approach known as polymerase chain
reaction or PCR and what PCR is is it's
an in vitro method so it's an in vitro
approach to assembly to essentially
amplify DNA and so let's say you have a
piece of DNA it could be a piece of DNA
in the genome and you know the sequence
of this DNA and there has base pairs
between this between the two strands so
normally for DNA replication to occur
what do you need what needs to happen
here
can the polymerase get in now No why not
miles
[Music]
yeah you have to unwind it right so you
have to denature at first so if you
denature it now you have to
single-stranded pieces of DNA right now
what would a polymerase need to
replicate that yeah Jeremy a primer
exactly right and if you know if you
know the sequence you can have a company
synthesize a primer that's the exact
sequence here and base pay base pairs
here and I'll just draw the five prime
end of the primer right there and now
this primer has a free three prime
hydroxyl here and if you added a
polymerase it would synthesize this
bottom strand here so this is known as
the forward primer and on the other
strand you can design a primer this
complementary to these bases here again
the 5 prime end is out this would be
known as the reverse primer and then you
could have the DNA polymerize synthesize
the opposite strand okay all right so
the step here will be to first denature
so the first step would be to melt or
denature the DNA double-stranded DNA so
you denature the double-stranded DNA
this is commonly done above 90 90
degrees Celsius and then the next step
is once you have these single-stranded
pieces of DNA you can act you can have a
primer present that anneals
to the opposite strands so you can have
primer annealing and if you have this is
commonly done that are between 50 and 60
degrees Celsius you have to cool it down
so that the primer can now base pair
such that not everything is denatured so
you have to cool it down for these
primers to recognize their cognate
sequence and base pair with it and then
once you have the primer annealed to the
template then you can add DNA polymerase
to
synthesize a new strand so DNA
polymerize for new strand synthesis and
this is commonly done at around 70
degrees Celsius and then you can repeat
this process over and over again and
each step you're going to double the
amount of DNA that you have between
these two primers okay so let me just
this is just a figure illustrates this
it's on the handout and online basically
you have your original double stranded
piece of DNA you denature it and allow
the primers to anneal new strand
synthesis then you take these new pieces
of double stranded DNA denature them the
primers anneal to those new strands and
now you get new strands and you just
keep doing this cycle over and over
again and you essentially amplify the
piece of DNA that's between the two
primer sequences okay so this is often
used in forensics because you can have
very little DNA and just by adding
primers you can really amplify the
number of pieces of DNA you have between
these two fragments so you go from
having very little DNA to a lot of DNA
ok any questions about PCR I'm going to
move on to something that all right so
all right I've really been focused on
discovery up to this point but I know
that a number of you are engineers and
you probably want to engineer something
ok and so I've had to and this is I'm
gonna tell you about a field that is
moving so rapidly I'm gonna probably
have to totally revamp my lecture for
next year ok and I'm gonna tell you
about genome editing so the last part of
this story genome or DNA editing and I'm
gonna tell you about a specific type of
system called CRISPR cast 9 which has
been in the news a lot and there's a lot
of excitement
about this approach in the context of
editing the human genome and possibly
curing genetic diseases who here has
heard of CRISPR cast 9 okay good so our
that's good our media is doing its job
okay so so who knows what it is okay
some of us know what it is I just want
to just give you a very superficial
overview of what it is and why it's
important and I'm gonna keep coming back
to it during the course of the semester
because I think it raises a lot of
ethical questions and especially in the
context of stem cells I need you to know
the foundation before we get into like
the really good stuff okay so let's see
so we're gonna engineer something so
we're going to talk about repairing DNA
and if we want to edit the genome the
way this is most often done is by making
a double-stranded break okay so if you
make a double-stranded break in a piece
of DNA it can be repaired one of two
ways
one is by non-homologous end joining
where the two pieces of DNA are
basically just shoved back together
again and this results often in
mutations so if you're trying to fix
something unless you're just trying to
break it that's probably not what you
want but an alternative approach to to
DNA repair that organisms have is
something called homology directed
repair okay in this case you can break a
piece of DNA and add a piece of DNA that
has a different sequence but with
homology near where the double-stranded
break is and in that case you can
replace the original sequence with what
you provide as donor DNA so it gives you
an ability to essentially change the DNA
sequence at a given locus if you're able
to cleave the DNA at a specific locus
okay so first I want to start with just
a thought experiment right you're all
thinking okay we need to cleave
double-stranded DNA and boy I just gave
you a perfect tool for that I gave you
all these restriction endonuclease
right so what's the problem with those
well let's think about the human genome
the human genome is 3 billion base pairs
and an eco r1 site looks like this
g-a-a-t-t-c so it's six nucleotides long
and if you think of just like a random
sequence of three billion base pairs
right you would get this sequence
randomly one out of every four to the
sixth times okay so that's going to be
about one every 4096 times okay so if
you get this in random DNA one every
roughly four thousand times if you use
it to cleave the human genome is going
to cleave like hundreds of thousands of
places in the human genome okay so we
need much more specificity if we want to
select let's say a given gene that has a
disease-causing allele and try to fix it
because if we use a restriction
endonuclease we just chop up the whole
genome and that would be bad okay so
specificity is the name of the game here
this is not specific and we need a tool
that's more specific okay and that tool
is going to be CRISPR cast nine and what
CRISPR cast nine is is it's essentially
an RNA guided endonuclease okay so it's
RNA guided and it's an endonuclease
restriction enzymes right they have
nothing to do with RNA they don't use
RNA to recognize their their nucleotide
sequence it's just a protein and the
protein recognizes the nucleotide
sequence in crass Burk CRISPR casts nine
you have an endonuclease which is cast
nine
bump this up so the endonuclease is the
protein the cast nine is the protein
that's the endonuclease but its
selection of a target depends on an RNA
molecule that is bound to okay so the
specificity comes at least in part from
what's known as a guide or a guide RNA
or single guide RNA that's what's most
most often used in genome editing so
this guide RNA basically allows this
enzyme to find a specific sequence and
the guide RNA is 20 nucleotides or looks
for homology for a 20 nucleotide base
pair sequence so you can see already
right we're doing way better than the
six base pair recognition motif we have
20 nucleotides and there are other
components of the system which increase
the specificity but this then you have
your cast 9 in blue which is the
endonuclease your RNA the guide RNA in
black and the template here is in gray
and what you see is this RNA sort of
exhibiting complementarity to this
target sequence and only if there's
complementarity between the RNA and the
target will this endonuclease get
activated and cleave at this site okay
so the RNA is sort of serving like a
guide dog for this for this endonuclease
to guide it to the certain location to
cleave okay
so the idea then is if you want to edit
the genome and why people are so excited
about this these days is you now have a
system that might allow you to generate
a double-stranded break in one specific
place in the genome and if you can do
that
then if you provide a donor DNA that
maybe has a different sequence if you
consider a disease allele right let's
say you know there's a gene that when
there's a certain allele Kazaa causes an
inherited form of a disease right you
could then take donor DNA from an
unaffected individual and take cells
from the affected individual and cut the
locus that's problematic and get a
repair of the defective allele using a
normal allele of the gene and that would
essentially rescue the function of that
gene if it were then reintroduced into
the patient okay you see sort of roughly
how this works okay so this is a very
sort of broad in general sort of
conceptual framework for how this might
happen let's say you have an individual
with a blood disorder let's say
sickle-cell anemia or beta thalassemia
those are inherited blood disorders
which lead to anemia you could remove
cells and what might be the best are the
stem cells from a patient and you could
then take those stem cells and use
CRISPR cast nine in vitro in cell
culture to edit that individual cells to
repair the genetic defect and you could
then reintroduce those to the patient
where if they're stims stem cells they'd
reoccupy the stem cell niche and produce
functional blood cells that would then
essentially cure the individual of the
disease this is how scientists are
thinking about the use of the system
nowaday and this hasn't really been
successful yet but there are several
clinical trials that are currently
underway where where people are trying
to show that this can be used to treat
human genetic diseases okay
so in the next year you are gonna hear
more about this almost undoubtedly as we
as we start to hear the results of some
of these patients there are concerns
about this as well I don't want to like
over blow it
there's certainly concerns we don't know
this is gonna work I mean people have
been talking about this type of stuff
since I was a student 20 years ago but I
feel like we're getting we're much more
advanced now and the tools are more
advanced and so I feel like we're kind
of getting to the point where there's a
much greater chance that this will be
successful these days than it was 20
years ago I just want to point out where
this system how it was discovered and
where it came from and I like this as an
example much as like for the fly genes
that define major signaling pathways
this is a discovery that came from
fundamental research on basically the
the ecology of bacteria okay so this
CRISPR casts 9 system essentially
evolved in bacteria as a form of an arms
race between bacteria and their
predators bacteriophage which are
viruses that infect bacteria ok so this
is an arms race between bacteria and
they're vicious predators bacteriophage
okay and what CRISPR is where these
enzymes and the system evolved from is
this is a form of an adaptive immune
system for bacteria which is pretty wild
in and of itself
okay so CRISPR is an adaptive immune
system for bacteria you haven't gotten
your flu shot you should get it we'll
talk about human immunity later in the
semester but this is where bacterial
immunity kind of I'm sneaking it in okay
so the way this works in bacteria what
CRISPR stands for is clusters of
regularly interspaced short palindromic
repeats so you can see already thank God
they gave it an acronym otherwise it
wouldn't be getting nearly as much buzz
because no one can say that and so where
this CRISPR came from is on bacterial
chromosomes of many bacteria there's
these clusters of interspaced short
palindromic repeats and the repeats are
interrupted by spacers and what
researchers discovered are these spacers
have sequence similarity and identity to
sequences that are from bacteria phage
okay so each of these colored sequences
here has some type of complementarity to
some type of bacteria phage okay and so
when a phage infects bacteria or some
bacteria what happens is that there's a
system to recognize that foreign genetic
element and take a piece of it and
insert it in the genome and that serves
as a memory for the bacteria to remember
that it got infected by that particular
phage okay and then later on what the
bacteria does is it transcribes this
region and forms these mature what are
known as CRISPR rnase where you can see
there's some sequence would recognize a
foreign genetic element so therefore in
the future if this phage came around
again what would happen is one of these
CRISPR rnase would recognize the foreign
genetic element through base pair
complementarity and it would know to cut
it and after the the target is cut is
then degraded by the bacterial cell okay
so this is a way for bacteria to
remember what viruses have infected them
and to have a defense mechanism against
it okay so it's a pretty cool system you
know what's also cool about this system
is it's an adaptive immune system
similar to how we sort of recognize
foreign pathogens which
different about it is this is heritable
it's incorporated into the genome and
the more phage the descendants of this
bacteria see the more of these repeats
you see okay so this is a heritable
immune system which unfortunately we
don't have okay so you should still get
your flu shot we'll talk about
vaccination later on have a good few
days and I will see you on Friday
you